a flotilla of Saudi oil tankers is
slowly steaming toward the United States
and into a chilly welcome for a US ally
indicative of how desperate these Petro
states are for to sell their oil to find
the place physically to find a place to
place their oil with the coronavirus
driving oil prices to historic lows all
US oil storage is expected to be filled
in the next month the Saudi move to
occupy much of that precious storage
space on the US Gulf Coast has been
called by some industry insiders an
economic Pearl Harbor a hostile attack
on US soil a coalition of 13 US senators
from energy States goes even further
calling it economic warfare Texas
senator Ted Cruz writes on Twitter 20
tankers filled with 40 million barrels
of Saudi oil are headed to the US this
is 7 times the typical monthly flow my
message to the Saudis turn the tankers
the hell around Cruz says the longtime
US ally is exploiting a pandemic to kill
the rival American shale oil industry
some analysts say he's right what is our
area rightfully doing as any other oil
producer is to get rid of the
competition and competition in this case
is expensive oil it with shale oil means
expensive to produce US leaders have
long nurtured strong bonds with Saudi
leaders even since the rise of shale oil
helped the u.s. overtake Saudi Arabia is
the world's largest oil producer three
billion dollars the fact that Saudi
leaders are now willing to risk the
anger of their American allies suggests
they believe the world's oil glut won't
end anytime soon with much of the world
on lockdown few drivers on the road and
fewer planes and ships are using fuel
oil prices are so low they briefly hit
negative territory this week at the
Chicago Board of Trade that left some
sellers actually paying buyers to take
it off their hands now many producers
are simply storing it and waiting for
prices to rise the u.s. can hardly turn
the ships away
the Saudi government owns the motiva oil
refinery in Port Arthur Texas America's
biggest it can choose what crude that
motiva refinery takes and you know at
times when it's tough market oil you
know you might as well just buy your own
oil even as American politicians lament
the Saudi incursion the ships sail ever
closer john Hendren al Jazeera Chicago